conosciutisi vi siano nuovamente qui a
questo video nuovo su questo gioco nuovo
chiamato canzone che non ho mai sentito
prima in 3 2 1 sera di ragazzi happy
with come sempre questa settimana
proviamo a fare livelli easy normali
tranquilli perché noi siamo belli
pensavo subito con un album dojo che mi
sveglia perché gli al fondo ci sono
quelle robe che devi stare attento
quindi primo livello se passo questo
vuol dire che il video andrà benissimo
quindi fam partito bene pam coltivato
molto bene mamma mia come faccio schifo
io sto gioco nessuno ma oggi la partenza
in modo non si sa perché perché farlo
quando non parlo fa tutto bene però fa
niente ragazzi di appunto oggi ero
sempre odiati perché non ho la
coordinazione fra schivarle rob e questo
è un problema grosso di degli appunto
oggi perché devi devi essere bebop di
aree tempismo essere coordinato io non è
uno nell'altro gli ottimo sono vivo a
posto chissenefrega di un arpione nel
naso fa niente c'è chi vive peggio
andiamo impossible già amico mio non c'è
niente di impossibile su questo gioco
per il sottoscritto perché ho fatto
talmente tanti livelli che il creatore
di questo gioco è sceso dal cielo e ha
detto senti ma basta io non mi sono
fermato siamo a livello al 360 di
happiness arriverò al 200 e sarò ancora
qua però questo non è facile alla
vediamo se riesco a fare una roba
decente dico saltare ea lanciarmi
madonna proprio lui e l'altro no no il
bellissimo perché non vi sono anche
disteso con il corpo proprio che
continua ad essere a chiocciola vedere
la famosissima posizione a chiocciola
del batman alfa version
ok qualcosa mi dice che questo nel
batman somiglia poeti ma fa niente
c'è uno che fa così come moneta sia
niente ero come una sigaretta va bene
non credo sia andata bene va beh
e vabbè fa niente dove sceglie i super
poteva non ho le gambe ma fa niente
basta hanno una visione di gambe e un
pipistrello proprio lui va bene
next david rees one tonne bomb ormai non
conosco p le mosse dei ragazzi fort koch
che pedata in bocca italia gestito in
italia purtroppo è addirittura perché
gli altri facevano schifo facciamo anche
il 2 perfetto da che si sblocca la
vittoria sta lì è perfetto vinto non è
mica perché ho parlato no figurati ma
devo passa che allora la palla bassa che
vada su vittoria però è più difficile
beccare halloween che vittoria perché
vittoria è laggiù
ed è anche bello grosso come risultato
breve è halloween che piccolo va beh se
lancio più falli insieme oplà ecco
stavo scherzando non puoi neanche
scampare alla morte perché di chiudere
proprio dentro la cosa quando ti arriva
la poppa bruttissimo papam bene vai solo
suono clean
bravissimo profeti chiudere ogni
possibilità di poter vincere anche se ti
arriva la bomba bruttissima sta roba che
maledetto halloween zio non è difficile
noi da te tipicissimo perché proprio
sotto il coso filippo ben raggiungibile
ma dai mi si sono bloccate le palle va
bene l'unico modo ragazzi e per beccare
l'aiuto el help porca vacca cielo quasi
secolare eccolo ok vi sono perché la
vittoria adesso che non è difficile
prima ripresa 20 volte non ci credo ok
no madonna con il suo salvato
meno male buono buono volo non è vero
non ho vinto più due palle clicca grazie
meno male perché se no ap due palle dai
ragazzi ma veramente 4 palle su tre
palle che frase strana che ho detto
può ancora vantare bene la madonna cosa
vuol dire pongono 99 per cento
impossible ma donna che aspetta nove
avevano ce la farò mai come si fa ma
idea di quante no ragazzi questo quasi
impossibile più grande che abbia mai
fatto
ce ne sono troppe ci sono troppi razzi
ma non ce la farò mai
no va bene ma vi rendete conto che ce ne
sono un miliardo e non è possibile
sono un miliardo di raggi non è il re è
impossibile non c'è punto dove io non
passano il nome dove non muoia o non vi
devo staccare dal fuoco oppure ce
l'avrei un'altra teoricamente se prendo
la bomba buona buon umore o no va bene
lo stesso ma che non cala troppo a
sinistra
porca vacca cero devo cadere sulle palle
brutta fra l'altro non ho capito o non
su altro nuovo finalmente perché era un
po che non facevo nuovo a just kids ma
che sono affatto sti ragazzi di così
grave da meritarsi st fini niente a
parte quello che è il mio boss ma con
una s sola quindi ok di successo
sa perché la v che brutto sto solo trova
mamma mia era veramente veloce
rifacevano noi facciamo un altro dopo
perché mamma mia e non rebuild the
return of rock e the prendevo fare
assolutamente così stampa no vabbè che
idea assurda poi razzi nelle mani ayane
sono morto e difficilissimo tanto per
care gente senza morire perché questo
c'è una spada spiana tissima occhio bene
porsche di ok ci siamo ragazzi sto
volando col mio piede ci sono dei
problemi questo floppy bird è diventato
bravo non hai mollato un razzo nord non
è mutato e di mollare devi rivolgerti in
avanti porca vacca difficilissimo a
posto devo trovare un modo per evitare
che mi ammazzino però è molto diceva
qualcuno l'ha testato suo livello e fini
bile nome non e fini bile io lo dico
prove molto bene per te ma se sono the
probabilmente vidal fastidio a porca
vacca
vabbè di rovesciata buono o sono passato
solo passato non è vero eccolo buono o
era ora
no no no no no perfetto ragazzi è
difficilissimo per la segue e non è
possibile non si può fare sta parte ma
manco riesco ad andare in avanti come
faccio a sorpassare delle punte
e vabbè è no ragazzi impossibile basta a
prendervi suter e tano le in crash mio
dio scrive di poi mettono sempre una sin
credibile o era un po che non facevo
brink lush col nonno jacques tra l'altro
tanto style è veramente brutto tonalità
nero così curva cos'è ma stai giocando a
twister non stai comandando un aereo
va bene livelli veramente strano try to
stop a questo e quello della cose che ti
manda sul muro ok però mi sono fermato
no non mi sono fermata è veramente
impossibile credo cioè se non mi sono
fermato prima che mi sono tenuto a porca
vacca no vabbè ragazze assurdo posso
cambiare personaggio ma senza cambiare
personaggio pure una roba infattibile
troppo veloce ci provo buona volontà no
no raga infattibile digiuno ramadan tisi
cipro un miliardo di volte questo va
troppo veloce
non puoi fermarti limite né conto
no ragazzi non si può fermare buono volo
che seguono questo mi piace buonissimo
sono atterrato con un calciatore che si
che strisciava le le ginocchia per terra
perché ha segnato un gol bellissimo però
non è andato ditte male proprio a fare
un altro scontro invece il politico non
mi era piaciuto potevate farlo anche
senza stordirmi l'orecchio sinistro però
va bene che fastidiosi rumori inuti a
cosa serviva a voi 9 miliardi per cento
impossible
ho sbagliato personaggio eccolo o
buonissimo stavo scherzando sia più
facili con il prima ragazzi
neanche il venuto singhiozzo ma se io
sono portato alla vittoria quindi niente
ma marple run sarda di tura veramente
difficile però io lascerei uk che un
peso inutile quindi facciamo prima non
era così hard e mi è piaciuto molto il
finale devo dire signori proviamo a fare
l'ultimo livello di oggi lo spy phone
che l'ultimo no mancava anche rock swing
effettivamente però non lo so chi non mi
sento molto di rock swing secondo me
possiamo chiudere così con questa
vittoria incredibile che farò con questo
salto senza guardare perfetto porca
vacca ronnie massoero veramente legato
alla fine certo ci credo proprio nuovo
ragazzi se non ho mai fatto uno spy
forza guardare o sì l'abbiamo fatto in
qualche video non mi ricordo che video
prova beh c'era stato un video che avevo
fatto un per e successi che ci penso che
avevo fatto bendato e pirlo
ho fatto un sacco di spy phone pure
porca vacca dove riuscirci ma edizione a
madonna è difficilissimo saltare senza
guardare ma dai
per un niente dai porca vacca salta
signori questa rapitori a crisi di oggi
prossimo episodio prossima domenica come
sempre da otto anni a questa parte dove
vi sia piaciuto si chiede anche
rilasciato un commentino e schiacciate
la campanella che molto importante per
tutti i video che escono è come sempre
ci vediamo al prossimo video della
ragazza
[Musica]